- Don't give me this thing,
"I have a difficult time with the time,
"and I don't have time
for this, none of that."
You have time, you make the time.
They wanted me to become a police officer
and to marry a girl by the name of Heidi.
(audience laughing)
And to have a bunch of
children and to run around
like the Von Trapp family
in The Sound of Music.
but that's not what I saw,
this was the vision of
my parents but not mine.
So he looked at me and he
says "ah Schwarzenegger.
"You have an accent, I cannot use you ah."
- He's an actor, politician
and former body builder.
He won the Mr. Universe contest at age 20
and went on to win seven
Mr. Olympia titles.
He gained world wide fame as
a Hollywood action movie icon.
He's Arnold Schwarzenegger
and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for
success, volume two.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're watching
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with you as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic music)
- When I used to do seminars
on how to become a champion
I would always ask people why
do you want to be a champion?
Or what do you want to accomplish?
Why are you training?
And if a guy will get up, and he will say
"well I want to train because
I think that if I get muscular
"and I feel like I'm getting
the kind of definition
"then I maybe can enter a
body building competition."
I said, "sit down".
Cause if you think this way,
you're going to be a loser.
You're never going to make
it because there's no maybe.
You got to get up and say,
"I want to be a champion.
"And I do whatever it takes."
The amount of hours it takes.
The posing, the this, the
that, the visualization.
Looking at training footage,
looking at motivational books,
reading this, whatever
it takes, I will do.
That's the answer I want to hear from you.
You can detect right away
those that are going to be
shaky and that will fall behind.
They will not go all the way.
And those that are very hungry.
And that hunger you have to develop
because you have to create
a goal for yourself,
whatever that may be.
A short-term goal and a long-term goal
and you got to go after that
and if you do not see it,
and if you do not believe
it, who else will?
Experiencing pain in
your muscles and aching,
and just then go and go on and go on
and those last two or
three or four repititions
that's what makes
actually the muscle grow.
And that divides one from being a champion
and one from not being a champion.
If you can go through this pain barrier,
you may get to be a champion.
If you can't go through, forget it.
And that's what most people
lack is this having the guts,
the guts to go in and just say
"I go through and I
don't care what happens.
"It aches and if I fall down,
"I have no fear of feinting in a gym."
Because I know it could happen.
I threw up many times
while I was working out,
but it doesn't matter,
because it's all worth it.
Everyone has a problem with time.
But the day is 24 hours and we sleep six.
Now I know there are
some out there that say
"Oh woah, woah, woah, woah, I need eight."
Well I say, "just sleep a little faster"
because the bottom line is
we have six hours of sleep,
24 hours are available
so you have 18 hours now available
to your work, your family, your hobbies,
and also to learn something
new or to do something new.
Which could easily be that you
want to learn a new language,
or that you want to read
as a New Years resolution,
have to read a book every week
or you say I'm going to
go and re-shape my body.
So you're going to go
and take this hour out of your schedule
and say I'm going to
train an hour every day.
So this is for most
people a huge challenge
but it is totally doable, I can tell them.
Because the kind of things that I did
when I came to this country.
I mean, I went to school, I
was working in construction,
I was working out my five hours a day,
I was taking acting classes
from eight o'clock at
night to 12 midnight.
I was doing all of those things.
I wanted to make sure that
out of the 24 hours of the day
that I don't waste one single hour.
Those hours were too precious.
And so then I just want to tell people
don't give me this thing
"I have a difficult time with the time,
"and I don't have time
for this, none of that."
You have time, you make the time.
I had this need of coming to America.
I mean, when I started
learning about America
at the age of 10 because
of geography lessons
and learned about America and about,
and saw the first photographs,
I remember photos in the textbook,
but also in Super 8
millimeter film footage
that they showed in the classroom.
You know, about the Golden Gate Bridge
and the Empire State Building
and the six-lane highways
and all this.
I said "what am I doing here in Austria
"with these little roads?
"I want to go and I want to
be part of the big deal."
And so I had always this
desire that felt like
the only way ever I would get to America,
because in those days it wasn't common
that you buy yourself a ticket,
no one could afford that.
So I had to accomplish something big
that takes me to America.
And then when I read
about this guy Reg Park
who won Mr. Universe three times
and then became a star in Hercules movies,
and then was in Italy filming,
and then in Hollywood filming,
I felt that could be the ticket.
I should become Mr. Universe,
I should become a second Reg Park.
Of course, no one really bought into that.
My parents thought I was totally insane.
And I remember that
I hung up pictures above
my bed for inspiration.
Pictures of Reg Park in his
posing trunks and all that.
My mother was so concerned,
she called the local doctor
and she had him analyze the wall,
because she thought that
there's something terribly wrong
that I have naked men above my bed.
And all of my buddies had
women hanging above their bed
and so she was concerned about that.
But I think that my parents really thought
that there was something terribly wrong
of being that driven.
Because I would come home at lunchtime
and instead of having lunch,
I would do 200 sit-ups.
And at night,
I will go to the stadium and
I will be lifting weights.
I will come home at 10 o'clock at night
and I will be continually lifting weights.
So it was like one of these
insanity in the military,
I will continue lifting weights.
No matter how the training was
and how tough the basic training was,
I would always then
lift weights afterwards.
And as a tank driver would have
on the side of the tank in the toolbox,
I would have my weights,
my barbells, my dumbbells
and my exercise bench,
and everything there.
In order to be, at any given time,
if we stopped driving
the tank and maneuvers.
At two in the morning, I will
be able to pull out my weights
and again lift for two hours my weights.
I was really a fanatic
about the whole thing.
But it's the only way you really
get the way I succeeded.
Because, I became at the age of 20
the youngest Mr. Universe in London
in the history of bodybuilding.
Because the youngest
before then was Reg Park,
the guy I was talking
about, at the age of 24.
But I became the youngest with 20,
but it was because I was so
serious about the whole thing.
And it worked, by the age of 21,
after I won my second Mr. Universe title,
I got an invitation from Joe Weider
who was the publisher of all
the muscle magazines in America
and also the person that had
the biggest warehouses of
weight training equipment,
and had food supplement
companies and all this.
And he brought me to
America, and so there I was.
Six years after my dream
started, I was in America.
I think it's the most important thing
that we have a very clear
vision of where we go
a goal, where do we go?
Because you can have the
best ship in the world,
you can have the best cruise liner,
but if the captain does
not know where to go
that ship will drift around the world,
and out there at sea and
will never end up anywhere.
This is exactly the
way it is in real life.
If you don't have a goal,
if you don't have a vision,
you just drift around you're
not going to be happy.
This is why it is so
important to have that vision.
Now I created that vision in Austria
because I grew up after
the Second World War.
Austria right along with Germany,
lost the Second World War, thank God.
And the problem was that
everyone was so depressed
because they lost the war
that there was alcoholism everywhere,
there was of course depression,
there was a terrible economic situation,
there was famine, there was
starvation and all those things.
And also it was kind of a
little place and narrow,
I felt kind of, I wanted
to get out of there,
I wanted to escape.
And I couldn't see myself
really do work there,
and to stay there, to work in the factory
or to work on the farm,
even to follow my father's footsteps
and to become a police officer,
I couldn't see that either.
And so I think that's what
my parents wanted me to do,
they wanted me to become a police officer
and to marry a girl by the name of Heidi.
(audience laughing)
And to have a bunch of
children and to run around
like the Von Trapp family
in The Sound of Music.
But that's not what I saw,
this was the vision of
my parents, but not mine.
And luckily one day in school
I watched the documentary about America.
And I found myself,
I knew exactly that is
where I wanted to end up.
I wanted to be in America.
- You had an early meeting
with Dino De Laurentiis and it
didn't go so well?
- Well, that was different
because Dino De Laurentiis
had an office and he wanted
me to be in Doc Savage.
And he wanted me to play
the villain in Doc Savage.
And I walked in, and I always kind of
have a mouth that sometimes
goes a little bit too fast
and I step on myself.
I walked into the office and I saw Dino
standing behind his desk.
And it was this huge desk,
ornate, gold and kind
of like French looking
or Italian looking, I don't know what.
But it was gigantic, it was
one of those partner desks.
And Dino, the only thing that stood out
was his chest and his head
because he's a little guy.
Dino's a really short guy.
So I looked in,
I walked into his office
and I looked and said
"Hi Dino,
"why does a little guy like
you need such a big desk?"
(audience laughing)
And to Dino De Laurentiis
you never say, you're little.
Because he saw himself as a giant.
So he looked at me and he says,
"Ah, Schwarzenegger, you have an accent,
"I cannot use you, ah."
And I said, again, stupidly,
"who is talking about having an accent?
"I mean, listen to you."
"Ah, are you a Nazi?
"Ah!"
And he walked away because
I had a German accent.
So that was the end of that.
So I left the office and
my agent came up to me.
He grabbed me really forcefully by my arm
and he said to me, he says
"I've been an agent for 15 years.
"This meeting was exactly
one minute and 14 seconds.
"It was the shortest
meeting they've ever had.
"You just
"everything up.
"God damn it, it took me
months to get in here."
So he was mad at me also.
So anyways,
so that's how the relationship
started with Dino.
But then when he bought Conan,
he came to Spain where we were shooting.
And the third day of filming
after he saw the dailies,
the footage that we had filmed,
he came up to me and he said
"Hey, Schwarzenegger, you are Conan, ah."
And he walked off.
And Milius came to me,
the director, and he says,
"this is the greatest compliment
that you can ever get.
"He said, you're Conan, isn't that great?"
And I said "I guess so."
And from that point on,
we created this really great relationship.
And we did movies together and
The Raw Deal and then Red Sonja
and Conan the Destroyer
and Conan the Barbarian.
And he became kind of
like a father figure.
He became kind of the Reg Park
that I had in the bodybuilding
world and Joe Weider,
he became that character
in the movie world.
That I could go to for anything.
Who would give me advice.
Who always had wonderful compliments
and kind of took me in
as part of his family.
And so that's why I always
will miss him very dearly
after he passed away.
The worst thing I think
you can do is retire.
Retiring means that you,
maybe have hated something
that you did your whole life.
And now you retire and finally
you get rid of this pain
or this horrible being on an assembly line
in some car factory or
something like that.
I don't know what it may be.
But people just sometimes
look forward to retiring.
I cannot imagine, why
would I want to retire,
from organizing the Arnold Classic?
I am having a ball here.
I love coming here every year,
you know what I'm saying.
I cannot imagine retiring
from going to Gold's Gym.
How can I retire from
playing chess with Franco?
How can I retire going
around and promoting health,
the environment or the fitness
crusade and stuff like that.
Or going to the Schwarzenegger Institute.
So I cannot imagine that
there is such a thing as retirement.
I think that it will
be over when it's over.
- [Interviewer] Define retired,
is that when you give up?
- Yeah, I don't know.
Some people just look forward to that
and like I said it depends.
We have to also understand one thing.
74% of the American people,
there's a poll that was done,
do not enjoy their work.
So this is why, and it's very tough,
it's easy for us to say
"why would I retire?"
Because I love everything I do.
But there's a lot of people
that don't like their work
and they're just doing it
because they need to make a living,
they have a family to feed
and so take the next best job.
But they don't really like the job
and they don't know then how
to switch over to another job.
So it's very tough, that's
why I always tell kids
in my success seminars.
Have a clear vision of
where you want to go.
What is it that you're
really passionate about?
And then go after that,
no matter what it takes.
Go after that.
As crazy as it may sound, because
you've got to do something
that you really enjoy doing.
- [Interviewer] Be true to yourself.
- That's right yes.
- You're a fantastic
direct response marketer
with your mail order business
can you talk to us about
that dollar into two concept?
- Well, you know we all pay taxes
and we all hate the idea that
you're losing that money.
But there's a difference between hating
that you lose that money
and hating to pay taxes.
I love paying taxes,
if it is the fair amount
and if it is used wisely.
I think we all have to contribute it
because this how you
set up social programs
that how you build infrastructure.
That's how we have a military
all of this kind of thing.
So that's great.
But I always had to belief
that the money that I pay in taxes
I want to make up
through wise investments.
So this is why I got into
the real estate right away
in the '70's and I started buying raw land
and developing that.
I started buying apartment buildings
and you know just think about it,
I mean it would be in, I remember in 1974
I bought my first apartment building
and we bought it for $215,000.
That's it was then a lot of money.
- Yeah.
- And put only found
like maybe $35, $37,000.
But within two years that
apartment building was worth
instead of the $215,
$350,000 and I sold it.
So imagine now how much gain there was.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I mean, so we made hundreds of percent
on my initial investment so
that's what I'm talking about.
See it, it takes you know
thoughts and ideas, can
make much more money
than actual physical labor.
And physical labor is
always part of the action
because I always say you've
got to work your ass off
no matter what you do.
Because now you have a great idea
but then you still have to implement it
and you have to hassle,
you have to go to the bank
get their financial
statement, do this and that.
Raise money sometimes,
then you go to look at a
thousand apartment building
to find the right one and
all this kind of things.
So you still have to work
but normally if you just physical labor
you can never make the money
that you can make when you have ideas.
So this is why it's important
I always tell people, I say
"the secret is, there's
certain don't think.
"Like when you get up in
the morning, don't think."
Just roll out of bed just
go on your live cycling
or go on a bicycle ride or
go to the gym, work out.
You know that's what you have to do,
and then read something
and learn something.
Don't even think about it.
But there's other times when
you have to really think
and you really have to get creative
and have a clear vision
of where you want to go
and what you want to do.
And that's what I always have
and that's what I always believed in,
always believed in making money
so that then you can
do something with that.
You invest in it in order,
eventually you create the family
you give some of it to your
kids and all that stuff
but also for charity.
Look, I have the
Schwarzenegger Institute at USC
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So we have to raise money all the time
and make money to pay for
that and the support there.
We have the R20 the
environmental organization
or any organization any idea is great
but if you don't have the money
you can't implement anything.
And so this is why it is important
that if it's an environmental organization
or if it is my after-school
programs, that are nationwide,
where we raise millions and
millions of dollars every year.
Or if it is just you know
living in a great mansion
or driving a nice Bentley in the Bulgari.
You know these the kind of things,
it takes money to do
all this kind of stuff,
so therefore I believe in
making one dollar into two.
And having a good time
when I pay my taxes.
When someone says "yes, yes Arnold.
"We have bad news,
"you owe $50 million in taxes."
I say "wow, yes!"
But then he looks at me and says
"what are you happy about?"
- [Interviewer] He's finally lost it.
- "Because that means we must
have made a lot of money."
To have to pay that much money in taxes.
And they say "yeah that's
a way of looking at it."
And so that's the way I look at it.
But I tell you that I was very fortunate
that I had great heroes.
I had great heroes that I could look up to
and I mentioned two of them Muhammad Ali
and Sargent Shriver, my father-in-law.
But there's other great heroes
like Gorbachev, Reagan, Mandela.
Great leaders like Mother Teresa,
Chancellor Kohl and Churchill
and the list goes on and on.
I mean those people had
such an impact on the world,
single-handedly they've changed the world.
We all can create change,
whether it is in our neighborhood,
or in our local schools,
or in our country.
It can be big but it
can also be as little as
just going to a school kid
that has problems reading
and teaching them kids how
to read or how to do math.
We don't have to just work on me,
we should also work on we.
Not just me but also we.
Remember that.
To lead a truly full
life you must give back.
You must leave the world a
better place than you found it,
because the bottom line is it is up to us,
I mean those rules that I've
given you are important rules,
but giving back is one of
the most important rules.
- In The Terminator you have
a very, very famous line.
Maybe your most famous line ever.
But you explained that when
you were learning English,
you didn't understand
contractions, you hated them.
So you thought the line should be said
differently than it was written.
So how would that line have sounded if
you'd gotten your way?
- I will be back.
(audience laughing)
I was as wrong as anyone can be.
I was arguing with Jim Cameron.
(audience laughing)
Jim Cameron wrote the script,
and so that's mistake number one.
You never tell a writer that
you want to change his lines.
And we had a battle
when we shot this scene.
I said, look, I just think
it sounds funny when I say
"I'll be back.
"I'll."
It's weird when I say that.
And he said to me, he says
"look Arnold let's shoot
it 10 different ways.
"Let's not get hung up on
should you say it or not,
"because you are going to say it.
"Because I wrote it.
"And I don't tell you how to act
"and you don't tell me how to write,
"so let's just move forward.
"Let's just shoot it 10 different ways."
So that's how Jim and I always talk,
kind of straightforward.
And we shot it 10 different ways.
Close-ups, medium shots,
long shots, zoom-in shots,
and everything you can think of.
By the time I did say it like 50 times,
we did all the different takes and shots,
it sounded right to me.
It sounded strong to me.
Because it just didn't feel like
it was strong enough
and machine-like enough.
And in the end when I saw it in the film,
I was happy that he convinced
me to say it that way.
And when you say a line like that,
you never know if that's the line
that becomes the most famous
line in the movie history.
And it just was voted as number
one line in movie history.
You don't know that.
I didn't even know it was
anything special at all.
Only when I promoted the film,
and I remember I was in New York
and I had people coming
up to me on the street
and saying to me and says "say it."
(audience laughing)
And I said "say what?"
They say, "the line!
"The line from Terminator."
And I said "which one?"
"Oh, come on, you know,
I'll be back line."
I said "okay, I'll be back."
"No, no, no, just the way
you say it in the movie."
And then I will say "I'll be back."
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's the one."
So I realized then,
jeez, what did we create,
a monster there or something like that?
It was like wow, it was
a big surprise to me
that it became such a big hit.
And it became bigger as time went on
and the rest is history.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Abhishek asked me too.
Also if you want to nominate someone
for the next top 10 video,
please check the description
for a link to a video
where you can vote for people
and put in your suggestions as well.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned,
that blew your mind, that
you're going to immediately
apply to your life or
your business somehow.
Please leave it down
in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
I just wanted to give a quick
shout out to Kam Jennings.
Kam thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, and the fun interview
we did on your YouTube channel about it.
I really appreciate the support man
and I'm glad you enjoyed the read.
- On the call we have one Evan Carmichael.
Owner and operator of EvanCarmichael.com
and Evan Carmichael YouTube channel
now with over 600,000 subscribers.
The author of Your One Word.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe, I'm hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- The body is very important,
but the mind is more
important than the body.
You have to visualize what that body
ought to look like in
order to make it win.
Because that's what creates then the will.
The will that you need to
go to the gym every day.
The will that makes you
go into the four steps.
The will that makes you go beyond
and you do your 500
pound reps and the squats
and you can't do another rep,
and your body is shaking,
it's the will that makes
you go one more time
down and struggle up one more time.
And so it's all of this
is the mental aspect
that motivates you,
and that makes the difference
of you being in the gym
full of joy and looking forward
to doing that extra rep,
and looking forward to doing
those extra hundred reps,
and the sit-ups and working
past the pain periods.
That all is the mind, that's not the body.
So this is why I think
the body is very important
but the mind is more
important than the body.
We have so many rules in
life about everything.
I say break the rules, not
the law, but break the rules.
My wife has a t-shirt, my
wife has a t-shirt that says
well behaved women rarely make history.
Well you know, I don't
want to burst her bubble,
but the same is true with men.
It is impossible to be a
maverick or a true original
if you're too well-behaved
and don't want to break the rules.
You have to think outside the box.
That's what I believe.
After all, what is the point
of being on this earth,
if all you want to do
is be liked by everyone
and avoid trouble?
The only way, that I ever got any place
was by breaking some of the rules.
After all, I remember that after
I was finished with my
body building career,
I wanted to get into acting,
and I wanted to be a star in films.
You can imagine what the agents said
when I went to meet all those agents.
Every one had the same line
that "it can't be done.
"The rules are different here."
Says "look at your body, you
have this huge, monstrous body,
"overly developed, that
doesn't fit into the movies.
"You don't understand.
"This was 20 years ago,
the Hercules movies.
"Now there is the little guys that are in
"Dustin Hoffman, Woody
Allen, Jack Nicholson."
Before he gained weight
of course, that is.
(audience laughing)
But anyway, those are
the guys that were in.
And the agent also
complained about my accent.
He says "no one ever became a
star with an accent like that.
"Especially not with a
German accent and yes,
"I can imagine with your name,
Arnold Schwarzen-schnitzle,
"or whatever the name is, on a billboard.
"Yeah that's going to
draw a lot of tickets
"and sell a lot of tickets, yeah right."
So this is the kind of
negative attitude they had,
but I didn't listen to those rules.
Even though they were very
nice and they said look,
we can get you some good parts.
We can get you to playing
a wrestler or bouncer.
Oh, maybe with your German
accent we can get you
to be a Nazi officer in Hogan's Heroes
or something like that.
But, you know, I didn't
listen to all those.
Those were their rules, not my rules.
I was convinced I could do it,
that if I worked as hard
as I did in body building,
five hours a day.
And I started getting to work,
I started taking acting
classes, took English classes,
took speech classes, dialogue classes,
accent removal classes I even took.
I remember running around, "a
fine wine grows on a vine."
Is it because Germans have difficulties
with the F and the W and the V,
so "fine wine grows on a vine."
I know what some of you now say is
"I hope that Arnold got his money back."
But let me tell you something.
I had a good time doing those things
and they really helped me
and finally I broke through.
I broke through and I started
getting the first parts in TV,
Streets of San Francisco,
Lucille Ball hired me.
I made Pumping Iron, Stay Hungry.
And then I got the big break
in Conan the Barbarian.
(audience cheer)
And there the director
said "if we wouldn't have
"Schwarzenegger we would
have to build one."
Now think about that.
And then, when I did Terminator,
"I'll be back"
(audience cheer)
became one of the most famous
lines in movie history.
All because of my crazy accent.
Now think about it, the
things that the agents said
would be totally a detriment
and would be impossible
for me to get a job,
all of a sudden became as asset for me.
All of those things, my accent,
my body, and everything.
So it just shows to you,
never listen that you can't do something.
And you have to work
your way up, of course,
run for something else first.
I mean it was the same,
and I when I ran for governor,
the same lines, that you
have to work your way up,
it can't be done.
And then of course, I ran for governor,
and the rest, of course, is history.
They said you have to start
with a small job as mayor.
And then there's assemblyman,
and then there is lieutenant
governor, and then as governor.
And they said that's the way
it works in a political career.
I said I'm not interested
in a political career.
I want to be a public servant.
I want to fix California's problems
and bring people together and
bring the parties together.
So like I said, I decided to run,
I didn't pay attention to the rules
and I made it and the rest is history.
- As the kind of movie star
that you are, were certainly.
You could be a dictator.
You could say "I want it."
And it gets done.
You can't do that now.
- You're absolutely correct.
And now this is different,
but look this is the great thing about it,
about adjusting from
one career to the next.
And the key thing always is,
is to keep your eye on the ball.
- Well speaking of which,
it took a lot of balls
to go cold turkey in politics.
- Yes, but they've never
had a lack of that (laughs).
I made up my mind, it
makes no difference to me.
Because I always say "what's
thew worst than can happen?"
That you fail.
I mean, that is, that's
really not that bad.